so this is my example of where you get
an equal to zero but it's not a point of
inflection okay the license Airport is
one again which you've already known but
I wanted to point out to you you can
turn back if you like in your working to
where you drew the cube root of x you
still have it in your books but I don't
have it on my whiteboard so I'm just
going to quickly redraw it
all right again nothing about the cup of
which way it's facing right just make a
geometric argument with me for a second
to the left of the origin to the left of
x equals zero
concave up or down clearly up right when
you have a look
excuse me on this side the concavity has
changed so being that concavity has
changed I don't actually care about
what's happening there like I exist the
function is continuous the second
derivative doesn't exist then there's a
discontinuity but it doesn't matter the
function exists there's a point there
and the concavity changes on either side
so therefore that is a point of
inflection now how do you find that like
you can't use this method to find that
point of inflection so how do you do it
very good you need to think about
remember we looked at last week think
about critical values this is why they
are useful category
he's the function right the rehearse
with me again how we get Beth bus and
second reduce what is the first the
third Exeter okay I'm just gonna be the
lazy I'm just gonna leave it like that
so that I can differentiate again which
gives me x s2 on 9x is good now you can
see right again
I'm not gonna bother writing it like
that but this implies the X term is on
the denominator so there's a
discontinuity okay that's all I need to
know something happens something
interesting happens right if there's a
discontinuity now I know I need to look
for a changing cream cavity and I will
do that I'll do that I'll say okay well
let's let's test out huh huh corner
right I'm gonna test my values I'm gonna
go X second derivative right here oh
there's a discussion your ear okay so
some people often say please do not put
0 there because the second area is not 0
okay but to the left to the right what's
gonna happen minus 2 over 9 times what
where is this only minus 1 to the power
of minus 5
I'm just gonna watch for a second I'm
not saying anything is because I already
know what sign answer is going to be but
you're telling me something else now
you've only missed something very
obvious okay this guy is negative one
well he multiplies by this guy right
which is to nine okay you care that my
heart is concave up alright and in
exactly the same way I'll have a minus
through the nine here it's concave down
I just needed you to get it not because
I said oh look I'm teacher said it was
okay right I wanted you to wait what but
I know what just happened you think
think think think think think
okay not just because someone told you
so I'll show you the change in concavity
right or rather the change in the sign
of it you can have any BAM I have a
point of inflection okay
one more thing that's worth mentioning
the reason why I have a point of
inflection I mentioned this before but I
wasn't gonna let big about it is because
there is a point the function is
continuous that the function is
continues you can't have a point of
inflection where you don't have a point
okay so for example this guy where have
I got space on the crown of bull
well it's not that hard to think of any
people what is the equation do you think
all this time this is the standard
rectangular hyperbola 1 over X right you
don't need me to tell you you don't need
to compute the first and second of
Duty's to show it is concave up and then
there's concave down hey cool I can make
a table just like this and there we've
started because doesn't exist a 0 this
concave down there we negative and
coltrane off plus it have I got a point
of inflection no because I don't have a
point
all right there's no places that oh
there it is it doesn't exist there's a
discontinuity in the function itself
whereas here the function itself is
continuous because there is no point